[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Geoffroy Cotonnec
membre du bureau du geek-up family et
Gilles Guillou responsable des stands
vous organisez donc le geek Up Festival
les 27 et 28 mai prochain au
Clayes-sous-Bois bonjour bonjour Avant
de parler du festival on va parler de
votre association giga up geek Up Family
vous avez débuté vos actions sur le
territoire en 2020 quels sont les
objectifs de votre association
l'association a principalement pour but
d'organiser un événement annuellement
donc le geek-up festival qui est comme
vous l'avez dit basé aux
Clayes-sous-Bois ce qu'on travaille en
partenariat du coup avec la mairie des
clés et pourquoi vouloir finalement
valoriser et organiser des événements
autour de la pop culture
c'est un constat qui nous arrive assez
naturellement on trouve qu'il y a on
trouvait qu'il y avait pas assez
d'événements sur cette thématique là ne
serait-ce que déjà sur l'agglomération
de Sky et après même au niveau des
Yvelines et donc on s'est dit plutôt que
d'aller constamment faire des
conventions sur Paris d'affronter les
transports en commun on va essayer de
monter quelque chose un petit peu plus
au calme dans nos parcs tout vert de
chez nous ce sera plus sympa et vous
avez justement été témoin de cette
engouement autour de la pop culture
parce que ça fait déjà depuis au moins
une dizaine d'années que la pop culture
prend de la place et qu'on s'intéresse
de plus en plus donc c'était essentiel
finalement de créer un événement autour
de ça bah totalement parce que en fait
faut comprendre que moi j'ai travaillé
pendant des années dans les conventions
donc j'ai fait beaucoup de conventions
depuis que je suis arrivé sur Paris et
en fait ouais c'est vrai on s'est rendu
compte que on n'avait pas assez de
d'événements dans notre région qui était
purement et spécifiquement réservé à cet
univers là donc on s'est dit que ça
serait bien d'en faire une et comme on
est des des fans de de ces univers là ça
dit vas-y banco les 27 et 28 mai
prochain donc vous organisé la deuxième
édition du Geek Up Festival et pour ce
festival vous proposez aux artisans et
créateurs de venir exposer alors ce fait
ce qui va est-ce que c'est aussi
l'occasion de découvrir la richesse des
Yvelines est plus largement diles de
France alors on a beaucoup d'exposants
qui viennent de des Yvelines ou
d'Île-de-France effectivement on a aussi
énormément d'exposants qui viennent d'un
peu partout en France des petits des
petits artistes comme des grands
dessinateurs ou des personnes qui sont
connues à travers toute la France et
même à travers l'Europe parce qu'ils
font des salons en Belgique en Italie en
Espagne qui nous font plaisir d'être là
parce que c'est un vrai ça me fait
vraiment plaisir mais c'est oui à la
fois la richesse des Yvelines comme vous
dites mais aussi du coup la richesse de
tout ce qui peut se faire dans l'univers
Geek et niveau programme vous ne laissez
pas les participants enfin les
festivaliers en reste vous prévoyez un
concours de cosplay solo le 27 mai un
concours en groupe le 28 mai jusqu'à
quand peut-on s'inscrire au concours et
quelles sont les conditions alors on
peut s'inscrire même sur place parce que
c'est un concours qu'on du coup qu'on
fait avec une association marseillaise
ah il sera cosplay et les conditions
pour s'inscrire sont
ce soit pas un cosplay qui soit
directement acheter tout fait sur
internet il faut que ce soit quelque
chose qui était fait il faut y avoir mis
du coeur
et en gros après il faut pouvoir
représenter son personnage et fournir
une bande-son une prestation de d'une
minute de mémoire une minute 30 et
ensuite voilà bon car je pense que tous
les passionnés savent ce qu'est le
cosplay pour ceux qui connaissent un peu
moins qu'est-ce que le cosplay alors le
cosplay c'est très simple c'est en fait
imaginez-vous vous êtes fan d'un
personnage par exemple je sais pas
Batman et donc vous décidez de
construire un costume de base de Batman
et après de faire une mise en scène en
s'inspirant des jeux vidéo des comics et
tout ça et après en fonction vous
arrivez faire une scénette devant le
public et là il y a le jury qui voit
regarde il vous demande peut-être même
de tourner devenir voir de demander
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait qu'est-ce
que vous avez pas fait avec quelle
matière vous l'avez fait est-ce qu'il y
aura un jury on imagine qu'il y a un
jury pour pour les départager qui seront
justement ces membres du jury alors donc
on a eu le plaisir de découvrir donc
Julie de Adventure et
qui sont deux plaisirsois et qui sont du
coup respectivement
ambassadrice Xbox et sosie de Lara Croft
et de Lucky Luke pour Johnny donc ils
seront là avec nous tout le week-end
pour conseiller les cosplayeurs juger
leur prestations et puis bah aussi pour
rencontrer leur public parce qu'ils ont
un public ce qui tourne beaucoup pareil
sur les conventions allez-y moi et aussi
il faut pas oublier qu'ils seront là
aussi pour faire une conférence pour
expliquer comment comment le cosplay a
été créé comment faire son premier
cosplay aussi oui c'est vrai donc il y a
également des conférences
sur quel sujet donc là on a parlé du
cosplay est-ce qu'il y a alors il y aura
beau comme on a énormément de
d'écrivains qui seront là on a quand
même des personnes qui ont on a quand
même le créateur de Polaris on a quand
même des des personnes qui ont travaillé
pour Marvel et DC et même pour y mettre
du comics donc qui vont être là pour
expliquer comment ils ont sont mieux des
seins quels sont leurs passions comment
ils ont créé leurs univers pour
permettre aux gens qui ont envie eux
aussi de créer un groupe univers d’être
de pouvoir le faire
et vous organisez également des jeux de
rôle alors pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas quel est le principe d'un jeu de
rôle alors le jeu de rôle ça va être
très simple je vais vous prendre un
exemple il y a dans les années 90 80 90
on a eu quelqu'un qui a dit tiens je
vais prendre le système de jeu de Orwell
qui était pour les sodas le plombs donc
avec des dés et je vais prendre
l'univers de Tolkien j'ai secoué bien
fort je sors Donjon et Dragon donc
Donjons et Dragons c'est en fait c'est
un univers on incarne un personnage avec
une fiche de perso avec des
caractéristiques on lance le dé pour oui
ou non réussir la caractéristique et en
fait le maître de jeu nous transporte
dans un univers où il sera nos yeux nos
oreilles et il nous fera mettre même un
décor devant pour avec des petites
figurines pour nous dire voilà alors tu
es dans quelle langue est-ce que tu
arrives à tirer ou pas voilà c'est aussi
que ça j'imagine que vous êtes passionné
on est d'accord que le jeu de rôle c'est
pas un jeu de société non ça se
rapproche un petit peu mais c'est pas en
fait
c'est de du terme d'improvisation parce
que comme on incarne le personnage comme
on dit action roleplay donc ça veut dire
qu'on incarne le personnage et on entend
de lancer des c'est plus c'est du
théâtre lu on va dire et enfin une arène
de sportive qu'est-ce qui attend les
festivaliers pour cette arène sportive
donc cette année donc malheureusement
nous n'aurons nous n'aurons pas de
Quidditch proposé l'année dernière mais
l'association de sabre laser de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines sera là pour
faire des démonstrations et des
initiations pour les ados et les adultes
voilà
aussi accompagnés de la de la 501e
compagnie donc des stormtroopers et un
Dark Vador en costume qui viendront pour
voilà générer des petites scénettes avec
nous nos amis Jedi alors pas de pas de
Quidditch mais les femmes les fans de la
saga Harry Potter pourront rencontrer
Josh Erdman et Louis cordis aka Grégory
Golle et Blaise Zabbini les deux
accompagnants de Drago Malefoy dans
Harry Potter qu'est-ce qui est prévu
avec les deux acteurs et quand
seront-ils présents alors ils seront
présents sur les deux jours de
l'ouverture à la fermeture du festival
et donc ce qui est prévu tout simplement
c'est de proposer au festivaliers de
venir les rencontrer passer un moment
avec eux pour discuter faire une photo
signer un autographe
et outre ça après ils vont aussi passer
sur scène pour faire ce qu'on appelle un
panel comme une fois aux questions pour
répondre du coup aux questions du public
sur toutes les questions qui pourraient
passer dans la tête d'un festivalier et
geek Up Festival sans inviter incarnant
la pop culture ça aurait moins de moins
de saveurs
de toute façon non c'est pour nous c'est
pas possible une convention sans inviter
il faut pouvoir proposer l'année
dernière on a eu le plaisir d'accueillir
des comédiens de doublage qui
travaillaient aussi bien sur des films
de Marvel que dans la japanimation et là
cette année effectivement on a pris un
cran au dessus on a été voir carrément
des acteurs internationaux mais on
espère pouvoir rappeler très rapidement
de nouveaux comédiens de doublage parce
que c'est ça nous manque et cette année
une partie de l'argent récolté par la
billetterie sera reversé à la Ligue
contre le cancer des Yvelines pourquoi
soutenir c'est très simple en fait faut
savoir que bon à la base moi je suis fan
de Stéphane Amel qui a créé la teamaro
fait contre le cancer donc au départ je
voulais venir
représentant européen et en fait bah ça
s'est pas fait et là ce qui se passe
c'est que en fait moi j'ai perdu mon
père ma mère et mes beaux-parents de
cette maladie et à l'époque on avait
l'équipe de Quidditch on voulait monter
un tournoi où tous les fonds
reviendraient à la lutte contre le
cancer et là on peut le faire avec
geek-up cette année l'année dernière on
a fait les restos du cœur cette année on
fait le cancer et
honnêtement là on est bien parce que
même au niveau prix on est à 5 €
l'entrée 8 € le weekend et 1 € ira
directement pour le cancer donc même si
vous voulez y aller en famille ça va pas
vous coûter trop cher et en plus
l'avantage c'est que vous vous aidez la
cancer donc c'était une bonne chose
chaque année vous allez de toute façon
soutenir une une association oui oui
tout à fait bah on a déjà en train de
commencer à regarder les associations
pour l'année prochaine on se tape encore
on va voir justement pour l'année
prochaine la troisième édition est-ce
que vous avez déjà des des idées pour
cette troisième édition beaucoup trop
beaucoup trop déjà une nocturne
j'aimerais ouais moi j'aimerais bien
rajouter j'aimerais bien proposer une
nocturne avec un avec un concert parce
qu'on a pas mal de personnes qui nous
ont contacté en disant qu'il voulait me
poser justement des petits choux
musicaux pendant le festival
mon compère ici présent grand fan de
catch j'aimerais faire venir faire venir
carrément une ligue de catch donc soit
soit celle de Nanterre soit celle de
Brest soit celle de Nice voir en
fonction de des gens qui sont intéressés
c'est ça donc voilà et puis parce que le
catch ça fait partie de la culture de la
pop culture donc ouais c'est c'est
important donc toujours toujours dans la
dans la pop culture est-ce que vous avez
quelques soutiens justement sur lesquels
vous avez pu compter pour pour ce
festival on aurait rien pu faire sans la
mairie des Clayes-sous-Bois qui merci
énormément de matériel et de moyens et
qui sont de très bons conseils
la communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines aussi qui nous
soutient beaucoup et
puis après tous nos partenaires donc
centrales comics sur Paris la librairie
JMS à Fontenay-le-Fleury cultura plaisir
aussi avec qui on travaille depuis peu
de nombreux soutiens pour pour
finalement un beau festival sur sur la
pop exactement
aura lieu donc les 27 et 28 mai prochain
aux Clayes-sous-Bois pour plus
d'informations on peut se rendre sur le
site geek up festival.fr merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et pour
revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]